오늘은 스페이스X의 모든 것에 대해서 알아보려고 합니다.
자 이 모든 것을 어떻게 알게 됐느냐
바로 몇 시간 전에 스페이스X의 상장 신고서가 공개가 됐어요.
그래서 그거를 좀 볼 거고
참고로 스페이스X의 상장 날짜는 6월 12일입니다.
자 어떤 것들이 좀 공개가 됐느냐
보면 우리가 기대하는 예상 티커 SPCX입니다.
어 스페이스X 사실 분들은 이제 요거 치시면 될 것 같죠.
그리고 생각보다 아직은 공모가나 공모 주식수
요런 것들이 공개가 되진 않았어요.
그리고 일론 머스크 지분율도 아직 공개는 안 됐고
핵심 숫자는 빈칸으로 남아있다 이렇게 보시면 되겠는데
5월 1일 기준으로는 일론 머스크가 스페이스X의 의결권의 85%를 보유하고 있습니다.
참고로 미국 같은 경우는 주식이 클래스를 나눠놓고 있어요.
그래서 클래스 B의 경우에는 주당 10표의 의결권을 부여를 하고
클래스 A 이건 일반 투자자에게 판매되는 건데 주당 1표입니다. 의결권이.
그래서 결론만 얘기했을 때는 일론 머스크는 지분율이 낮아도
회사 전체를 사실상 지배할 수 있다 이렇게 보시면 됩니다.
밸류에이션에 대해서는 한 1.5 트릴리언 달러 정도로 예상되고 있는데
뭐 더 넘을 거다 요런 얘기도 있어요.
2 트릴리언 달러가 될 수도 있다 이런 얘기도 있습니다.
참고로 1.5에서 2 트릴리언 달러면
3개의 회사들 시가총액 중에
2 트릴리언 달러면 한 6위 정도 되겠네요.
그래서 TSMC나 브로드콤 요정도급에 되는 회사가
하나가 상장되는 거다 요렇게 보시면 될 것 같고요.
자 스페이스X의 미션 우리는 뭐하는 회사냐
이걸 봤는데 약간 일론 머스크 F인가 이런 생각했어요.
그래서 한번 좀 읽어보면
우리의 미션은 생명을 다행성 종으로 만들고
우주의 본질을 이해하며 의식의 빛을 별들에게까지 확장하는데
필요한 시스템과 기술을 구축하는 것입니다.
당신은 아침에 일어났을 때 미래는 멋질 거야 라고 생각하고 싶을 것이다.
그것이 바로 우주를 상해하는 문명이 된다는 것의 진정한 의미이다.
그것은 미래를 믿는 것이고
미래가 과거보다 더 나을 것이라고 생각하는 것이다.
그리고 별들 사이로 나아가 그 한복판에 있는 것보다
더 가슴 뛰는 일을 나는 떠올릴 수가 없다.
뭔가 10대 소년이 우주를 꿈꾸면서 쓴 그런 글인 것 같죠.
스페이스X와 XAI가
어땠는가 실적이 2025년에 187억 달러의 매출을 기록을 했습니다.
이거 한국 돈으로 25조 30조 이 정도 되겠죠.
연간 매출이 그 정도고
이 세그먼트가 있는데 스페이스는 이제 우주로 쏴주는 거
발사체 업이라고 하죠.
그러니까 위성 같은 거를 우주로 쏠 때
스페이스X가 이제 우주로 쏴주거든요.
우주 택배 약간 이런 느낌 그런 비즈니스를 하는데
그게 이제 스페이스 사업부고
커넥티비티 사업부는 스타링크라고 해서
우주 인터넷 사업이라고 보시면 됩니다.
위성으로 중개해주는 인터넷 사업 통신사 같은 거죠.
그러니까 그런 사업부가 있고 이제 AI는 X랑 이제 그록이 하는 거
그러니까 X는 여기서 이제 트위터 옛날에 인수한 거
여기에다가 그록이라고 언어 모델 만들고 있는 게 있죠.
그래서 그게 이제 AI 사업부라고 보시면 되고
매출이나 영업이익은 대부분 다 커넥티비티 사업부에서 나옵니다.
그러니까 스타링크에서 매출도 대부분 나오고
영업이익도 나오는데
스타링크에서 번 돈을 대부분 AI에 쏟아 붓고 있다.
데이터 센터에 쏟아 붓고 있다라고 보셔도 될 것 같아요.
스페이스 사업부도 사실상 어저스티드 앱 있다.
그러니까 일회성 비용을 제외한 그런 이익을 봤을 때는
이익이라고 볼 수가 있기 때문에 대부분 다 AI가 돈을 까먹고 있다.
결국 스페이스X가 상장한 이유는 데이터 센터
이 AI에 감당하기 위한 수많은 돈들을 넣어주기 위한 거다라고 볼 수가 있겠어요.
2025년도에도 캐펙스만을 봤을 때 무려 20밀리언을 쏟아 붓고 있는데
캐펙스의 대부분은 AI 인프라라고 보시면 됩니다.
그러니까 이게 사실상 미래 사업으로 기대를 하는 거죠.
그리고 핵심 사업부 중에 하나가 바로 로켓입니다.
아까도 말했던 이제 우주로 택배 보내주는 거
우주로 물건들 보내주는 거 이제 그 사업인데
이 사업에 대해서는 아예 경쟁자가 없죠.
스페이스X가 사실상 로켓과 관련된 사업을 정의했다.
라고 봐야죠.
누적 궤도 발사도 가장 압도적이고
특히 펠콘, 펠콘9과 펠콘 헤비가 지금은 스페이스X의 주력 사업인데
이제 수치는 압도적이고 경이롭다고 볼 수가 있습니다.
그래서 전 세계의 궤도 투입 질량 점유율
궤도에 많은 위성들이나 물건들을 올렸는데
그것의 질량 점유율, 사실상 시장 점유율이라고 볼 수 있겠죠.
그게 이제 80% 이상이고 재사용도 되게 많이 했고요.
스페이스X의 과거는
펠콘9이라면 스페이스X의 미래는 스타쉽이다라고 볼 수가 있겠습니다.
일단 덩치부터 압도적이에요.
자유의 여신상이 93미터인데 스타쉽은 무려 120미터고요.
건물 하나를 그냥 올리는 거다.
이렇게 보시면 되겠습니다.
참고로 제프베조스가 창업한 회사죠.
블루 오리진의 가장 대표적인 로켓 뉴글랜드 한 98미터는 되더라고요.
사이즈가 그래서 스타쉽은 완전 재사용 로켓으로 개발을 하고 있고
성공하면 발사 비용을 과거 평균 대비
99% 이상 낮출 수 있다고 하고요.
또 스타쉽이 이제 세 번째 버전을 테스트를 하고 있는데
버전 첫 번째랑 두 번째는 다 성공을 했고
버전 3는 완전 재사용 기준으로 100톤을 지구 궤도에 보낼 수 있다라고 설명을 합니다.
스타쉽은 단순 우주 탐사용이 아니라
위성 휴대폰 서비스 우주 AI 데이트 센터를 가능하게 하는 핵심 인프라라는 거를 강조를 하고 있어요.
사실 우주 AI 데이트 센터가 엄청나게 많아서
많은 질량을 우주로 보내야 되는데
기존의 펠콘 라인으로는 사실 수지 타산이 안 맞습니다.
결국에는 엄청나게 크게 규모의 경제로 많은 물건을 저렴하게 보내야 되는데
그게 가능한 시기가 되려면 스타쉽이 일단은 성공해야 된다라고 말씀을 드리고 싶고
V1, V2는 사실상 성공을 했다라고 보시면 되는데
이제 V3부터가 진짜 일하는 로켓이라고 보시면 됩니다.
지금까지는 탑재를 별로 안 했어요.
많은 물건을 실어 보지는 못했습니다.
일단은 올라가느냐 이게 너무 중요했기 때문에
그런데 이제는 진짜 일하는 로켓이라고 할 수 있는
무려 100톤이나 탑재하는 V3를 이제 발사를 할 예정이고요.
보니까 한국 시간으로 5월 22일 그러니까 지금으로부터 24시간 뒤에
이제 12번째 발사를 하는데 스타쉽 V3의 첫 번째 비행이더라고요.
IPU를 더욱더 빛내줄지 아니면 살짝 아쉬운 모습을 보일지는
24시간 뒤에 보시면 될 겁니다.
개인적으로는 성공 자체는 시간 문제가 아닐까
내일 실패하더라도 큰 대세에는 지장이 없다라고 저는 생각을 하고요.
그리고 아시다시피 스타링크는 이미 가입자만 해도 천만 명이 넘는 엄청난 서비스입니다.
그러니까 전 세계의 위성을 기반으로 인터넷을 가능하게 해주는 서비스고
전년동기 가입자가 무려 100%나 증가를 했습니다.
전쟁 나도 스타링크가 매우 중요해지죠.
왜냐하면 특히나 전쟁이 나면.
인터넷 인프라 같은 게 다 박살이 나기 때문에
이 위성을 통해서 데이터를 수신 받는다는 것에 의미가 매우 올라가고 있습니다.
그리고 또 오지에서 사막이나 바다 산악지대 이런 곳에서도
인터넷을 가능하게 하는 게 바로 위성인터넷이다라고 볼 수가 있겠고
또 하나의 어떻게 보면 스페이스X의 미래라고 할 수 있는 건 바로 XAI겠죠.
그래서 XAI 사업부가 있는데 뭐 아시다시피 그록이 있고요.
그록은 이제 언어 모델이고요.
AI 모델, AI 모델인 그록이 있고 트위터에 해당하는 거죠.
X가 있고 근데 이제 X가 그냥 뭐 SNS를 끝나는 게 아니라
사실 또 의미가 있는 게 뭐 유저를 붙잡아 놓는다는 의미도 있고
결국에는 여기서의 데이터를 갖고 또 그록을 학습시킬 수가 있는 거라서 의미가 있습니다.
참고로 콜로서스 1, 2가 있는데 이건 데이터 센터라고 보시면 돼요.
이거를 약간 네오클라우드 같이 다른 또 AI 회사의 이 컴퓨팅 자원을 팔고 있죠.
이런 것도 상당히 흥미롭고.
그다음에 테라펩이라고 해서.
칩을 만들어야겠다.
로직 반도체건 메모리건 이런 걸 만들어 보겠다라고 해서 또 시도하고 있는 게 테라펩이 있습니다.
그래서 페이스엑스도 항상 그랬던 회사인데 일론 머스크의 회사들의 가장 독특한 점들은
일론 머스크가 어떤 것들을 외주를 준다기보다는 수직 계열화를 전부 하려고 하는 경향이 있어요.
그래서 반도체까지도 수직 계열화를 하겠다라는 그런 강력한 의지가 있고
또 매크로 하드라는 게 있는데 참 이게 마이크로소프트를 거꾸로 한 겁니다.
그래서 에이전트인 것 같아요.
AI가 회사를 자동 운영하는 듯한 에이전트 플랫폼을 만들고 있습니다.
그래서 아직 제대로 발표된 게 많지는 않은데 또 어떤 게 또 에이전트가 나올지 또 지켜보시면 될 것 같고요.
스페이스X는 AI의 핵심 병목이 모델보다는 물리 인프라 전력 GPU 데이터 센터 반도체 칩 제조라고 보고 있습니다.
그래서 AI 경쟁은 누가 더 싸고 빠르게 컴퓨팅 자원을 계산 자원을 확보하느냐의 싸움이라고 보고 있습니다.
그래서 AI 경쟁은 누가 더 싸고 빠르게 컴퓨팅 자원을 확보하느냐의 싸움이라고 보고 있습니다.
그리고 결국에는 IPU를 하는 이유이기도 한데 결국에는 우주 데이터 센터를 만들기 위해서 IPU를 하겠다라는 겁니다.
왜 우주에 데이터 센터가 있어야 되느냐.
AI 수요가 현재 폭발을 하고 있고 그에 따라서 데이터 센터의 수요가 너무 커지고 있는데
특히 가장 쇼티지 중에 하나인 게 데이터 센터 전력 수요거든요.
데이터 센터에 이제 전력망을 붙여야 되는데 지구의 전력망은 이 AI 수요를 따라가기가 어렵다라는 겁니다.
그런데 태양 에너지의 대부분은 우주에 있고 우주에서는 태양광을 더 지속적이고 효율적으로 쓸 수가 있다라는 거고요.
그래서 그거를 하기 위해서 스페이스X라는 회사는 이 모든 것을 하기 위한 준비가 되어 있으니까
그러니까 우리가 이제 IPU를 해서 돈을 끌어 모아서 결국에는 우주 데이터 센터를 하고
우주 데이터 센터를 성공하면 가장 저렴하게 대용량으로 데이터 센터를 돌릴 수가 있는데
이 AI의 싸움은 컴퓨터 센터를 돌릴 수가 있는데 이 AI의 싸움은 컴퓨터 센터를 돌릴 수가 있는데 이 AI의 싸움은 컴퓨터 센터를 돌릴 수가 있는데
컴퓨팅 자원의 싸움인데 컴퓨팅 자원을 가장 저렴하게 만들어낼 수 있으면 결국 우리가 AI 전쟁에서 승리할 수 있다라는 얘기겠죠.
그래서 2028년부터는 AI 컴퓨트 세털라이트 그러니까 AI 컴퓨팅을 위한 위성을 시작할 수 있다라는 얘기를 하고 있습니다.
정기적으로는 매년 100기가와트 규모의 이거 100기가와트면 그냥 지금 전 세계에 있는 사이즈보다 더 큰 거 아닌가?
그 정도급은 될 거예요. 진짜 어마어마하게 큰 거예요.
그래서 매년 100기가와트 규모의 컴퓨팅을 우주에 올리는 것을 목표로 제시합니다.
그러니까 지금 지구에 있는 것보다 더 큰 규모의 컴퓨팅 파워를 돌릴 것이다 라는 그런 목표까지 제시를 했고요.
스페이스X는 결국 무한 확장하는 거대한 플라이휠이다. 거대한 선준환 시스템이다라고 볼 수가 있는데요.
이게 어떻게 플라이휠이 도느냐. 일단 어떻게든 로켓을 올렸죠.
일론 머스크가 정말 옛날에 2007년인가 2008년에 거의 망할 뻔했는데 자신의 전재산 때려 박아가지고요.
어떻게든 로켓을 올렸습니다. 그런데 이제는 로켓이 옛날에야 비용이 비쌌는데 이제는 저비용 로켓까지 왔거든요.
그럼 스타십이 어떻게든 저렴한 가격으로 지구에 있는 물건들을 우주에 올리죠.
그런데 당장 우주에 올리면 돈이 되는 게 뭔가요? 바로 통신망입니다.
통신위성을 일단 우주에 다 올려서 그 위성들로 스타링크를 돌려서 가입자들에게 데이터 사용료를 받는 거죠.
그래서 돈을 벌고.
돈을 벌어가지고 AI 연산 인프라에 쏟아붓는 겁니다.
자 근데 AI 연산 인프라에 돈을 때려 박으면은 AI가 가장 잘하는 게 효율화 아니겠습니까?
그래서 AI의 효율화 그리고 AI의 어떤 지능들을 이용해서 다시 우주 하드웨어를 최적화하고 자율 운항을 고도화해서 발사비용을 다시 하락을 시키는 거죠.
그럼 발사비용이 다시 하락을 하면 로켓은 다시 저렴하게 물건들을 올릴 수 있고.
또 로켓이 저렴하게 물건들을 올릴 수 있으면 스타링크를 운영하는 것도 더 저렴하게 할 수 있고 또 AI 데이터 센터를 위해서 올라가야 되는 물건들을 훨씬 더 저렴하게 가능하게 할 수 있습니다.
그럼 이제 선순환이 도는 거죠.
자 그 외에도 엔트로픽에게 컴퓨팅을 이제 팔고 있어요.
그래서 월 12.5억 달러 월 1.7조원 8조원 이 정도 되는 2조원 좀 안 되는 돈을 매출을.
2029년 5월까지.
만들어내는 걸로 계약을 했습니다.
그러니까 진짜 엄청난 숫자예요.
이거 진짜 엄청난 숫자고.
향후 수십조원의 매출이 이미 예약이 되어 있다는 거.
뭐 그런 것들이 또 있고.
하지만 좋은 얘기만 쓸 수는 없습니다.
상장 신고서에는 리스크를 써야 되거든요.
그래서 어떤 리스크들이 있느냐.
스타쉽이 실패하는 거.
스타쉽이 뭐 만약에 지금 이제 많은 물건을 이제 올리는 것들을.
어쨌든 스타쉽이 이제 거의 최종 단계로 와 있는데.
갑자기 계속 실패할 수도 있는 거잖아요.
그래서 그런 리스크도 있고.
또 규제 리스크도 있습니다.
뭐 발사 허가가 안 난다거나.
주파수를 허가를 못 받는다거나.
뭐 이런 리스크가 있고.
AI 규제가 또 있죠.
특히나 이제 그록 같은 경우가 뭔가 이제 음란물.
그록에서 아시는 분들은 아시겠죠.
물론 저는 잘 모르지만.
그록에서 원래 이제 음란물 같은 걸 좀 만들 수가 있었거든요.
저는 잘 모르지만.
어쨌든 그것과 관련된 법적 리스크.
또 생성 AI들이 대부분 또 법적 리스크들이 좀 있어요.
그래서 데이터를 갖고 왔다.
뭐 이런 것 때문에 소송을 받고 있는 것들이 있어가지고.
그런 리스크들이 좀 있고요.
그 다음에 대규모 캐펙스.
대규모 자본 지출.
그러니까 한마디로 돈을 때려 부어야 되는 리스크가 있고요.
또 부채가 있습니다.
부채가 2026년 3월 말 기준으로 해서 291억 달러니까.
한 40조 원 정도 부채가 있는 것 같고요.
또 일론 머스크 개인에 대한 의존도가 있습니다.
일론 머스크가 CEO기도 하고 CTO기도 하고 이사회 의장이거든요.
그래서 이런 또 리스크가 있고.
머스크가 갑자기 건강이 안 좋아질 수도 있는 거니까.
뭐 그런 것들도 리스크고요.
그리고 이제 기술 자체가 미검증이 됐다.
근데 일론 머스크는 생각해보면 여러분들.
일론 머스크는 검증이 된 기술.
기술을 갖고 회사를 운영한 적이 없는 사람입니다.
그게 또 일론 머스크의 매력인 것 같고.
또 경쟁 자체가 있죠.
경쟁 뭐 다 치열합니다.
AI도 치열하지.
통신업도 경쟁이 치열하지.
우주도 경쟁이 매우 치열하고요.
그 외에도 환경과 전력 이슈가 있습니다.
그래서 과거의 스페이스X는 그냥 로켓 회사인데.
미래의 스페이스X는 어떻게 될 거냐.
로켓도 하고 위성 인터넷도 하고.
AI 데이터 센터도 하고.
그룹도 하고 X도 하고.
우주 컴퓨팅 인프라까지 제공하는 정말 종합 회사로.
탈바꿈.
탈바꿈 하겠다라는 게 스페이스X의 목표다라고 보시면 되고요.
나쁘게도 보면 이거 채찍피티에서 돌려서 이렇게 나온 것 같은데.
나쁘게 보면 너무 많은 초대형 프로젝트를 동시에 추진하는데.
원래 일론 머스크가 그리는 큰 그림 자체가 도화지가 찢어질 정도의 큰 그림을 그려왔으니까.
지극히 일론 머스크스러운 회사다.
이렇게 저는 생각을 합니다.
그리고 2025년 매출이 한 18빌리언 좀 넘거든요.
자 근데 이제 2026년에 100% 넘게 성장한다고 가정하면 그냥 편의상 매출 한 40빌리언 정도 나온다.
이렇게 치면은 2026년 포드 PSR이 한 50 정도 되지 않을까.
시장가치가 2틀리런이라고 치면은 이 정도 될 것 같아요.
대량 느낌이.
그래서 이게 싸냐 비싸냐 두 가지 시각이 다 있을 것 같습니다.
사실 이 정도 규모된 회사가 PSR로 시장가치를 평가받는 건 드문 일이기는 한데.
워낙 또 시장성이 매우 큰 비즈니스를 하고 있으니까.
스페이스X는 전체 도달 가능한 시장을 28.5조.
달러로 정의를 했습니다.
야 이거 어마어마한데 되게 재밌는 게 뭐냐면 이 28.5조 달러를 정의하면서 스페이스나 커넥티비티 시장은 거의 없어요.
이 전체 도달 가능한 시장이 별로 의미가 없고 전부 다 AI입니다.
그러니까 AI가 뭐 어떻게 보면 인류의 이 지능을 대체하는 거니까.
사실상 이 전체 도달 시장 규모가 진짜 냉정하게 보면 지금 지식 노동자들 육체 노동자들이 받는 월급이다라고도 볼 수가 있기 때문에 뭐 그렇게 보면은 도달 가능한 시장이 매우 크기도 한데.
이거를 뭐 크다고 볼지 당연하다고 볼지 이제 여러분들의 몫인 것 같고요.
어쨌든 6월 12일에 IPO를 하니까 어떻게 될지 두근두근한 마음으로 한번 지켜보도록 하겠습니다.
그럼 저는 또 다음 영상으로 돌아올 테니까 여러분들 구독과 좋아요 알림 설정까지 해야지 계속 재밌는 주식 이야기 들어보실 수 있겠습니다.